welcome back to Las Vegas now it's time
for our law Vegas now segment and in
light of the recent killing of George
Floyd by a Minnesota police officer that
was all recorded by a citizen Erik
Palacios is back to discuss ways we can
help as citizens when witnessing or
experiencing injustice welcome back Erik
thank you for helping me tackle this
very sensitive topic I heard a quote
recently that said racism is not getting
worse it's just getting filmed and this
is something that we can do as citizens
to help people in these in these
situations of misconduct or injustice it
is it's it's a very sad situation and
the officers involved don't always like
people to film them so I want to make
sure legally can i film the police when
I'm pulled over or if I'm in a
questionable situation or if I see a
questionable situation if you're in
public or if you are in your vehicle you
always have the right to film especially
if you think you might be in danger
there might be some action against you
that is inappropriate you are free to
record it if the officer questions you
on it be very respectful but say I have
the right to film this interaction and
I'm going to do so and it's not going to
get in the way of what you have to tell
me or what you have to do hmm great
advice and what if you what if you want
to get involved a little more is that a
good idea or how should you how should
you interact at that point if you want
to get involved or you feel the need to
get involved it's probably because it's
a heated altercation or there are things
going on that you don't think are
correct
or right to do so by getting involved
you can put yourself and those around
you at more risk since the officer is
already feels threatened and is already
taking action which others might think
is inappropriate so the best thing to do
is not to get directly involved you can
however film the situation and if you
feel compelled to do so you can talk to
the officer in a respectful manner and
ask him to think about what he's doing
or if he's using
more than necessary force if you want to
film it should be for the correct
reasons and it's to document maybe some
behavior that was was inappropriate but
you don't want to yell at the police
officer or raise the level of the threat
or anger or anxiety that's going on if
you want to record it it's to make sure
that it doesn't happen again and that
there is evidence of what took place so
always keep in mind to be as respectful
as you can all right thank you so much
Eric for helping me tackle this one I
hope this inspires someone to stand up
for someone else and you know do the
right thing it is and it's hard to know
what to do especially when you see an
officer that that's angry or doing
something that you don't think is
correct
but the best course of action is to be
respectful and try to help out if we can
thank you so much Eric for more
information give Eric Palacios and
associates a call the numbers right
there on your screen you can also visit
their website at Eric Palacios law.com
there's more on Las Vegas